today we're going to make you a
productivity
master
if you want to know how i stay
productive how i run
10 youtube channels how we make six
videos a day how i manage a team
of 30 plus people and don't go crazy in
the process and still
have time for my life and my wife and
everything else i use
a program called evernote to keep me
organized
and today i sit down with one of the
biggest evernote experts
in the world to break down exactly how i
run my life and my business through
evernote and he gives me feedback
tips and suggestions on how i could be
doing even better
so if you want to become a productivity
master and learn behind the scenes what
it takes to make my entire business run
you're going to love this session
between me and charles byrd
charles has also put together a private
special free training just for you guys
believe nation
called kill the chaos which will help
you master your productivity and reclaim
your life
if you want to join in on the free
training you can go to
evancarmichael.com
chaos it's on here on the screen but
it's also down in the description below
now on to my one-on-one with charles
charles welcome aboard man
thanks for having me evan it's a
pleasure to be here so charles does a
lot of things but he is especially an
expert in evernote and i
love evernote i use it to run my
business i use it to run my life
all of these youtube videos that you see
on the channel touches evernote
multiple times i have over ten thousand
notes so just looking today
we got ten thousand notes that i've
added to evernote and so for anybody
who's had
struggles trying to organize their
business and workflow this is a special
video where you get to learn
the behind the scenes that i've never
talked about of how i run my channel and
business
and then also get torn apart by charles
it's going to tell me what i'm good at
and where i suck and get some ideas to
improve and charles has also given us
a very special free bonus training that
we're going to link up in the
description below if you want to check
it out
and before we dive into the content
charles what's going to happen on that
free training for people
we're going to talk about information
domination to kill the chaos of
information overload and enable you
to put your finger on anything you need
within five
seconds across your business across your
personal life
what this does for you is liberate your
time a minimum
of three hours a week that adds up to a
144 hours a year or 18
working days of reclaimed time and your
stress levels will
drop so win-win i'm excited i want to
save three hours a week man i'm excited
so if you guys want that free training
customized from trials there's a link in
description go check it out
okay charles let's uh let's dive in let
me show you how i use evernote and you
can
tear me apart and tell me what i need to
fix sounds good
so here's my evernote as you can see
here 10
785 notes so there's probably tons of
things that i'm doing wrong that you can
help me fix
but i thought the best thing to do to
start with is to walk through my
workflow
for making some of the videos on my
youtube channel i think that'd be cool
for my audience as well to kind of see
the behind the scenes of how the sausage
is made so
a top 10 series is kind of iconic on my
channel it's what people know
a lot of my videos for and so you can
see we've got 1300 different top tens
that we're doing
and this is this is our format where
somebody will come in
one of my team members will go and start
doing the research of the different
clips that we want to pull
and putting timestamps in someone else
will come in and put
suggested teasers someone else will come
in and put the description
uh and then thumbnail text so four to
five people are going to be looking at
this document
and making tweaks and changes and
improvements before i even
see it then i come to filming day and
i'll i'll say all these rules i'll i'll
check them out
they're pretty good now where i'm not
making a ton of tweaks and changes my
team has
is are they're rock stars now so we know
what we're doing
i'll come in and film it and then it
goes to my editor who will pull all
these clips and put it together
a tiny minor thing is if we haven't done
it yet this would actually be a star
at the front that means evan needs to
review it if i've filmed it i turned it
into
a dash and then if it's gone live on a
channel we turn it into we just remove
my editor will remove the uh
the dash and that's what it'll look like
final version so that's like
super high level i don't know any quick
thoughts that come to mind
from what we're doing right now as a
matter of fact more than one
okay okay let's go so for one i want to
give you props for
using this so effectively and in fact
you
basically run your business out of this
with a very
large team and 10 000 notes is
is a beautiful place to work from so
i am a massive fan of using tags
tags will liberate quite a bit in your
workflow
i have no tags on here it says add tag
basically
tags you can start putting like
what it is who's who's assigned to what
you could actually be doing
handoffs based on tags once
it's ready for the editor you tag the
editor and when
he or she searches um that will come up
for for the tasks it's it's actually
smart how you're using the asterisk do
you use the check box for anything in
here
the simple uh it's on the the toolbar
there the
effect box yes i don't think so so
okay so so check this out maybe i'll uh
request
control here and i'll i'll just show you
a couple quick things
okay some of these tools are actually
very
simple but they're also very effective
and
end up being quite powerful for you so
if there's a specific task
i uh since this isn't my stuff i'm not
clear on what's the task and what's not
but when there is a task
you can simply use these check boxes i'm
not saying these are tasks i'm just
demoing
yeah and another way to do them is with
the
square ended parentheses you can just
type them
like that so you don't even have to go
to the
okay the bar and then as you're going
through and things are getting done
you can check them off on the way when i
have my team working on stuff i actually
have them put their own name as a tag so
i can pull up anything that they've
touched and
you can also um you could create a
workflow so when it does go to the
editor
they can search for any tag with their
name
and see this stuff really quickly and
search for
any open check marks within any of the
notes assigned to them
got it so we can see now ray is so
there's a little picture of ray who's on
this note right now so he's on my team
ray is in charge of doing the thumbnails
so he's probably looking at his videos
saying
oh i need to go through the thumbnail
he's doing it because
it's got the little yeah it's got the
little dash next to it
so that's why he's here he's looking for
the dash but you're saying we could just
tag this
to rey and then he'll just have to look
look at anything that's tagged rey and
he knows he needs to do it
absolutely so throughout this whole top
ten list here
that's gonna save me a lot of time man
that seems great
uh the thing is you have such a lovely
head start
once you start applying these tweaks you
truly will
start saving time and you'll have a lot
clearer visibility so
let's say we're on some other thing from
you know one of these down here
we can right now we're looking at these
top 10 notes that's the
notebook that we're in and
now we can filter by tag here so this is
filtering by
tag in the top 10 notebooks so right now
there's
there's one there's rey uh and we can
clean up that view
immediately to see exactly what rey
should be
seeing um and can rey
untag himself and then tag the next
person
uh he certainly can yes nice yeah okay
so that creates more visibility the way
you've been using the um
the way you've been using the asterisk
i'm also a fan of using
emojis and because they have color and
so forth
i'm not positive if that works the same
on a pc but on the mac
i i do quite a bit with emojis and
then you can spot stuff without actually
even reading it your eye can tell you
what's going on
okay you can do some cool stuff simply
with those and then
uh filter by those tags in fact um
you know as as it goes through the
workflow you could basically just
document the steps of the workflow
create tags for those create
owners for those and you can see as it
goes along
uh how the tags are coming in and then
filtering by them that's one easy win
right off the bat yeah i love that
there's some other cool things i'm going
to
clear that tag
search out of here and you can actually
even make an index of
of all of these so if i highlight
uh ctrl a let's see if that works
on your pc there
so what i've done is highlight all of
these projects by please
please don't press delete charles
[Laughter]
i just selected all of my notes 1300
videos
that's right now check this out we can
tag all of these at the same
time so these are top ten i would i
would highly recommend tagging them top
ten
okay and would you recommend having the
tag instead of the notebook
okay well since you have such a defined
workflow this way already
um you you may want to
consider bringing them both in if if
you're starting um
typically if someone's starting fresh
and they're they're using it personally
i am a fan of relying on the tag because
tags are simply like the ability to put
a note in as many notebooks as you want
they're simply called tags so it gives
you
a lot uh simpler paths to get to things
you could search by top 10 then you
could search for
ray and filter down precisely
right um so they do work together just
fine i'll show you one other quick
feature while we have these highlighted
and that's creating a table of contents
out of
everything that's highlighted what does
that do so when i click
this i it created this table of contents
of all of these and you can simply click
to get to any one of them okay and then
how do you
how do you update that as new ones come
in you would
recreate that simply by doing the same
thing doing the same thing and then
check this out just as a side note
related to shortcuts this table of
contents
you can make an app super easy to get to
you name that for the top ten yeah and
then
um you basically have this simple method
to navigate
with internal links between these notes
uh it gets to be a lot of fun but let's
okay hold on hold on
i'm just too i'm geeking out i'm too
excited that's shortcuts
can you put a tag in the shortcuts yeah
check this out so if we go to if we go
to tags which
you actually do have a few um any one of
these tags
yeah let's use mastermind there's four
things in there
you can drag the tag over as a shortcut
oh my goodness
and then when you pull that up uh you're
good to go
which effectively then it's
it's like a notebook but the power of
tagging is
is pretty wild i'll uh i'll give you a
quick example i was speaking at a
mastermind in croatia there's like 250
people
on this island and a video crew and i
wanted to tell the video crew
about a conference coming up um but i
forgot the name of the conference
it was a video conference forgot the
name of the conference
and forgot the woman who invited me to
speak and i was a panelist
with randy zuckerberg mark's sister and
you'd figure that would be the end of
the conversation if you don't know the
name of the place or who invited you
but there's a tagging method i use which
i'm going to give you
a little rhyme to remember this by okay
it is who what where
why tags are better than apple pie
okay it's dumb but you'll remember it
who what where why tags are back okay
and the reason that's useful is here i
am on an island
i knew the conference was in san diego
that's the where so i searched for the
tag san diego
and i knew it was a video conference so
i searched for the tag video
and bam the broadcaster authority summit
with tamara thompson came up immediately
so it it is a superpower to be able to
find stuff
within five seconds and that's that's
really one of the keys in here
wow i'm getting all sorts of ideas now
so one of the things that i do is i have
a list of all the people that i'm you
know i try to stay in touch with
and when i'm when i'm traveling when i
go to a city
i'm always struggling to remember like
who's in this city that i might
be able to meet and connect with right
like where are you charles where are you
right now
uh i'm in the napa valley near san
francisco and i do the same thing man i
have
tagged for austin san diego
new york london and then you can just in
fact i did this i was traveling to
london i pulled up a list of anyone i
knew in london
and pinged them all and met up with some
friends when i
flew over there so your your brain is
working exactly how it should
okay okay okay so we've looked
at tags for kind of workflow for
assigning
projects to people so that's great with
anybody in the team i guess it could
also be
even if it's a solo entrepreneur just
tagging it for
if you've got eight steps in your
production cycle you could tag it for
whatever step that you're on
absolutely this is also great for
creating um
like workflows sops standard operating
procedures you can document these steps
and then if something's deep diving you
can make
a note for a deeper subset topic and
link it back to the first
and link them between each other so it
starts getting very fluid
i love it okay and so you can assign
projects or look at different
you know where you are in the workflow
uh we've talked about the
who what is it who's something why
something apple pie
who what where why
tags are better than apple pie um it it
works really well i've had
several private clients some of which
you know yeah that
one of them pinged me she's like i have
a question about evernote i'm like hey i
can jump on the phone she's like no no
no
i just need the rhyme i just need the
rhyme
and then she put it on the sticky tape
like the printout
ticker tape thing on top of her monitor
it works really well
when are using it for your contacts for
the events you're speaking at for your
team
absolutely so and i'll point out the
the four tag process it doesn't have to
be four
it could be less it could be more but it
makes it easy to think of what the tag
should be
because when you're new to tags they
feel very nebulous and you're like well
how am i going to think of that in the
future
that's actually the advantage of tags
so if i were speaking at digital
marketer in austin
and flying out there i would tag it
digital marketer i would tag it
speaking i would tag it based on the
name of who booked me to speak
um and so that way i can find it
in in context i um i had a doctor's
appointment last week
and it was somewhere i hadn't been and
i'm driving off
and i'm like oh no where where am i
actually supposed to go so i just
pulled up the tag kaiser and it was in
front of me in
in one second and every time you follow
the system
you feel like a rock star you feel like
a superhero
and every time you don't follow the
system it's
quite the opposite so would you do
i now i got like a million questions in
my head would you do
even something like this right so you're
you know you you
graciously volunteered your time to to
hop on and be with me here which i
appreciate
would you say would you make this into
an evernote because right now this would
be in my google calendar
but would never touch evernote that i'm
talking to charles byrd
on this day at this time do you turn
calendar notes into evernote as well
yeah so as a habit which uh something
you'll learn about on the free training
that we're doing
is something i call the power trifecta
it's the combination of tools
workflows and habits they they go
together
seamlessly so this was on my google
calendar to meet
and as a habit when i sit down to meet
with anybody
i'm making a new note i'm tagging it
with their name in
my case i tag it uh notes as well
i use that as a tag and then this is
content creations um so i'll tag it
that way as well and then i put together
a little outline before this call
and what my team actually does for me
which anyone could do themselves quite
easily
is in the calendar
i'll have my next appointment because
i'm usually running quite a few calls in
a day
and there's an internal evernote link
pasted
in the calendar notes so i
have a call i click on zoom i click the
evernote link and it takes me to a
template
ready to go for the call i should show
you templates too
because those are quite handy are you
are you do you happen to be using any
templates right now
uh probably not so
okay so we'll make one real quick and
then i'll show you
how to save it and this saves you time
on
anything that you're duplicating like
yeah okay so if you look at if you look
at any of those notes
in the top 10 like the folder that we're
in now or it's not a folder what is it
notebook
notebook um it's the same
basic structure every time
that my team then basically goes to an
old one copies and pastes it in
oh cool cool yeah now this one's a
little different because you put the
check boxes we edited that one
but yeah yeah like it's the same basic
template all right so what we're gonna
do
i'm gonna i'm gonna duplicate this note
and we'll turn
it into a template and then save it as
such
okay so um i'm right clicking here
by the way this is where you can make an
internal link
and copy it internal link means if you
sent me this link it wouldn't take me
anywhere
this is just for you as the account
holder um
uh you can make an external link that i
can open so you can share things with
people whether they use evernote or not
i do it every day um anyway so i'm going
to duplicate
this note so we're going to clean this
up to become
a template so let's put in the charles
charles byrd top 10.
let's call it that so we know there we
go perfect
it's a preview of what's to come nice
okay so i am a fan of using
um tables but in a little different way
than you expect i use
them as a headers so this is a header
thumbnail text
i'm going to cut that and then i'm going
to make a one cell
table okay and then i'll paste that in
and then i'm a big fan of using color
because your eye can jump to different
sections of the document without
thinking
because you get used to the color uh so
i do that for for each section um
let's see if i see just so that you have
a background behind it's like
highlighting it
almost but just bigger yeah since we're
making a template you don't have to do
what i'm doing every time when you open
it it will just have those fields and
look pretty and be ready to go
um this one is video title right oh
okay yeah yeah i pressed paste i got
ahead of myself
too excited yeah and you could pick uh
whatever colors you want really but
as you can see it just makes the layout
crisper it's it's got some color and
energy to it
and then i presume this part would all
be blank right
the intro would be there and then so
like new intro would be
another category okay so let's do that
so again this is just a one cell table
and anywhere that is appropriate you can
create more than one right um so
and that was in red so we can do it in
red and it auto adjusts
the the font color like it turned out
white because it's on the dark
background
exactly wow all right intelligent i like
it
okay so we'll pretend this is done i
recognize a lot of this other stuff
wouldn't
be in here but just for the sake of um
[Music]
time uh you do the same thing on the
rest of these you clean up the links
that
shouldn't be in every template just like
the course structure
and then what you do is come over to
these
three little dots on the top right okay
save and template save as template now
this gets very cool because
for these different like i have one for
um
regular meetings i have one for joint
venture meetings i have one for
consulting clients
so check this out you make a new note no
matter where you are
so i'm clicking the new note button and
then
what's the one button you see in the um
snap look at that okay so when we click
this
by default it will go to some of
evernote's templates that they pref
provide we want to go to my templates
wow
and bam there it is wow
oh my gosh i mean i don't do a lot of
this but my team is gonna freak out
they're gonna freak out this has been
such a manual process
okay this is great and then how do you
if i wanted to edit
the template where am i going uh to
edit the template um basically we go
create a new you save it as a new one
yeah i make a new one
and then so i'd make whatever changes i
wanted and then
uh save it as a new one and uh when
you're in there you can
delete older ones but yeah so
having a structure for going into
meetings um
you just feel more grounded in
everything you're doing because you have
a framework for it
and my whole philosophy is remove the
thinking
uh think about it once design it well
and then just live in flow state as much
as possible because
every time we try to reinvent the wheel
we're
getting out of flow state and we're
wasting time and energy
so you're using it as a crm too
basically
i have a lot in there i also use
crms that talk to evernote so every note
that i put in
automatically goes into the crm
i have um a frictionless system between
multiple tools but
evernote is the foundation yeah
that's where it's cool what you're up to
because
uh the initial tool i recommend for for
most anybody is evernote and creating
workflows around it which you have a
beautiful head start
at 10 000 notes i'm uh i'm rocking 46
000 notes
that's crazy okay and i can find
anything in five seconds
uh so it's very empowering
so are you not really using the
notebooks is it just tags is how you do
everything
and notebooks are just okay okay so
candidly speaking on the personal side
it's basically
fully tag reliant on the business side
we do use notebooks for different things
and there's there's reasons for that so
for many of your viewers this may be
less relevant but i'd point out
someone like you running a team someone
like me running a team
i use evernote business for a couple
quick reasons one you control the
accounts you control
who you're giving accounts to and the
access so if you
have a contractor come in that may leave
you're controlling the account and the
way
beyond the account itself the the way
you control
access is through notebooks and
workspaces workspaces is a additional
feature for evernote business
i don't recommend evernote business to
most people but someone like you i
certainly would
okay i got it now
maybe one one other quick thing so if i
look at if you look at the sides or
under my shortcuts
what i try to do is i have different
things for different days and those
numbers maybe there's a better way to do
this
represent days of the week so one is
monday
so that's my team stuff two is youtube
day
tuesday three is wednesday uh four i'm
doing meetings so i don't have notes on
that but i could so like here so two
tuesday youtube day
here are a whole bunch of my ideas i
just use this as a brain dump on the
right
side there of different ideas that i
have
for my youtube channel um i put them as
one two
three uh he's already he's already
making it easier for me he's doing it
i put it as one two three you know up to
six seven because
uh it's just alphabetical so that
you know monday tuesday wednesday
wouldn't be in the sequence that i
wanted to be
i don't that makes sense yeah organizing
so
those numbers even in the notes do those
also represent days or those ratings of
which ones you want to work on first
uh inside the notes i don't know that we
have numbers uh
there there are here five dash yeah yeah
so
yeah so that's actually a link to a note
it's not a notebook that's going right
to the note the shortcuts to the note
okay the shortcut is to the note and the
that uh number represents the day of the
week
right so that's friday so five is friday
got it
okay see these ingenious little things
people come up with
uh so you're doing we're just wrong and
you know we're trying
you tell me okay so
when it's tuesday you're clicking on the
the youtube one here or yeah
okay and then what is your method for
sequencing did you did you wake up on
sunday and then go
choose what you want and put numbers
based on the day of the week you want to
do the work
i have different days where i do
different things and then i just try to
map
my my calendar to those activities so
tuesday is youtube day if i get like on
the right side there it'll say video
improvement ideas
new video ideas these are things that
i'm not working on right now
but i want to and i just i need a home
for it so this is basically like my
brainstorm
dump of all my youtube ideas so that
they're all in one spot
um they're not ordered by anything uh
when i have extra time on a tuesday i'll
look at it and i'll just see
what do i feel like working on like what
caused my attention
that that works uh one thing you could
consider
is uh adding maybe a number rating as a
tag
on priority so your favorite ideas
you can filter by number one
and then then you're seeing the scale
down list and you can choose between
those
and i also use a tag uh let's say you
did pick one
and you wanted to work on this
particular one
and that's what you're choosing to do
right now
yeah i use a tag called current focus
okay and
that tag is cool because when you're
getting to work on something
nice there it is you can restrict what
you're seeing so your brain's not
telling you
all the 80 things you're not doing right
now it's telling you the one thing you
are doing right right
yeah and entrepreneurs we have non-stop
ideas for what we should be doing
oh i love it if you're typing in the tag
how do you make sure that you don't just
put in current instead of current focus
or current idea or something like how do
you make sure you don't put the wrong
tag so for example if you're in you're
in napa valley
um what if i put in like
i could tag at napa valley but i might
target san francisco
oh right like or bay area yeah or like
sf or something like
sure so the way i do that is
sometimes i'll i'll use more than one if
i think
i might think of it yeah and then what
happens
is when you're doing searches you'll
find
there's uh 20 notes
as san francisco and one note as bay
area and then you're like well clearly
i'm not using that so you
put it over and delete the other one got
it why not do full text search
like why not just make a note i could do
a note call it charles byrd
and put in that into the text of the
note
and if i search bay area it's going to
show up still apply like why a tag
instead of full text search
i love that question and i have um
a few other productivity friends uh
that we have these conversations so i i
have a friend who does it exactly like
that
he's a highly productive dude running a
multi-million dollar company
so there is more than one way to to do
any of this
that said um here's why
so let's say you were looking up the
word car
um it's evernote's gonna find anything
that says car
carpet carpe diem whatever uh
anything that has those letters it's
gonna find where when you look for the
tag you're only getting what you
intended let's say you had a 100 tags in
here or even a thousand
um and you search for
this may not be the best example because
this is current focus it's what you're
working on right now
but my point is when you're filtering by
one tag
and then click this again so this is the
second time to add a second filter
it's only showing you the tags used in
conjunction with the first tag
okay got it so and tags on hierarchical
is that even a word hierarchical
like there's there's notes notebooks and
notes it's a hierarchy right
tags it's just tags but you're just
doing the double filter
yeah i i think technically you can drag
one tag under another but it's
only visual it's there's not there's no
real hierarchy
and it's pointless with this system got
it
makes sense that's cool yeah man dude
this is crazy
i mean i feel like i know a lot about
evernote and i realized i don't know
anything about evernote this is this is
awesome i see a lot of different uh
applications for me for my team
now what are you so i mean we've got the
free training people can go
sign up now you're gonna dive deep into
this stuff even more
what what are you gonna cover inside of
that free training
okay in the free training we're going to
cover every core
feature of evernote and how to use it
and that's
free um we'll also talk about
the power trifecta the combination of
tools workflows and habits because
you could understand this tool inside
and out if you don't have the habit
triggers to use it
correctly when you're going through your
day it won't be there to save your
your tail later so we we talk about
those triggers we talk about
um really just best practices and
it it's quite liberating people go
through that
and um one of my clients shredded
93 pounds of paper out of his life and
can see his desk for the first time in
20 years and
according to him now his wife loves him
more
solving solving relationship issues too
all right this is great
yeah and one woman wrote wrote in and
it's just interesting how people phrase
it she she
said that the program and the what i
teach in there
um improved her emotional well-being
and the reason that's true even though
it sounds however it sounds
you feel different if you know you can
get to what you need when you're hunting
for something it's a
really annoying feeling especially if
you're under pressure to get it quickly
so uh it truly is liberating
and uh you you feel more empowered you
start like you are already doing you
start finding other optimizations and
it's a
upward positive spiral of momentum that
starts improving all kinds of things in
your life so
uh it is definitely worth worth your
time
for someone who so again free training
guys links in the description go check
it out i'll be there
i'll be learning um i'm super pumped for
for people who might be looking at this
or saw my screen
and feel overwhelmed they've never used
evernote before
they maybe not have great systems
they're maybe afraid of new technology
like
what is the what do you say to them
who's afraid of getting started
okay well the sooner you do get started
the sooner you'll
have this liberation and we start very
basic we're like here's how you make a
note
here's how you find a note here's how
you tag a note
we talk about the difference in
notebooks and tags
and so we baby step our way right in but
here's a fact probably 93 percent of
your audience has heard of evernote and
three-fourths of them have it on their
phone
right now and if i popped into someone's
office or home and we were talking about
it and i mentioned i have an evernote
training their eyes would light up for
just a second because they recognize a
word i said oh i have that
and the next thing they would say is ah
but i'm not really using it
so people are aware of this they know it
can improve their lives
they've not been given a structure to
snap it into
their world and i have a very simple
structure to do it it's very effective
i mean that was my reaction i heard
evernote was cool
when downloaded it and this is literally
my reaction i like make a note and i'm
like
it makes notes like right i'm not gonna
how how do you use this for anything
like this is uh it seems silly
and um then i was uh i talked about this
a little in the webinar but
i worked in the silicon valley and i was
walking in
to the office and one of the vps was
like hey we're looking forward to your
presentation and i'm like cool next
tuesday like usual he's like no we need
everything in
half an hour and i'm like what i go to
my
office i'm sweating bullets literally
well not
bullets but i was sweating i had that
tight
solar plexus like you know fight or
flight because
i had to pull in all this stuff and i
did not have enough time to do it and it
was so high pressure i was managing a
five million dollar project
and that was the day i'm like i have to
figure out a method
to find whatever i need immediately and
that's when i
revisited evernote and designed the
system
and it's it's so good
evernote's asked me to come do facebook
lives on their campus with their whole
team
um i've met their ceo multiple times
even have him plugging my
courses on video and i was uh
i was introduced to one of evernote's
board members under the context of
consulting him
on applying uh evernote in his uh
in his business so um you're in good
hands what will uh
get you outcomes very easily i love it
and i think the key
you know for me was just finding one use
case
and getting used to it and then you can
apply it to so many different areas i
think
the first use that i found because i was
like you i got it okay i could take
notes
i don't know what's the difference
between a word document and and this
like why i save it here
it was actually travel so when i was
traveling for vacations to different
cities
i would have an evernote and i could put
it in my i would
i would make my travel plans in my on my
computer
but then it would also automatically be
on my laptop and automatically be on my
phone
and it had offline access that's what
got me to business i think business
you have when you pay for business you
could get offline access
uh maybe they've maybe that they changed
that but um
i just used it for my travel and it was
so valuable and then i slowly started oh
i can apply it here and i could apply it
here and i could
so it's it's um you just have to find
one use case and that makes it
worthwhile i think absolutely and i
we we didn't talk about i assume you're
also using web clipper
i'm not dude
okay well um oh my god it should be
i've seen it oh dude you will be
very happy um so are you covering that
on the webinar
training in the training you definitely
have to i'm there
dude it would be a big win for you and
the team
oh man it's like it's just not it's
awesome how much you can do with it i'm
a power user with 10 000 notes and
there's still so much more
okay i i've heard of it i've seen it uh
i guess it's like most people where
you've got it on your phone but you're
just not using it enough so
cool yes please put it in the training
so guys you want the training you want
more from charles
i'm going to be there he's maybe going
to kick my butt a little bit more
and and make me feel like a newbie again
which is great because that's how you
get more productive and learn
the link is down in the description go
join for the free training we'll see you
there
charles mann appreciate the wisdom the
nuggets the knowledge
um really valuable you're to save me
time my team's time and hopefully my
audience a bunch of time as well
my pleasure thanks for having me so if
you want to hop on the free training
with charles and how to
master your productivity and reclaim
your life
click the link right here below i'm
going to be joining in too
i'll see you there